Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
jegger and four bikes, and
concentration
, it's a translation that'll be in the world soon.
The leader of Gelato 5,
Red Gelato, Ai Karl Road,
and the dreamer, Gekkou, the battle garden leader,
Shirigami Princess, To a certain Vezelay,
they are absolutely incompatible, crossing the walls of the organization and
doing forbidden merits and demerits.  There is,
this is fate,
right?  My interest in love
is over,
but how much will it cost
? Level Arthur
Our relationship returns to the direction where anyone will definitely tell
me Marumaru won't be able to be with Hashiba I
know I'm
not good at keeping secrets, but I'll keep this secret
eroanime
How much do you stand with the world? We are
us
[music]